le retour dans la bonne humeur pour ses
trente six randonneurs qui ont marché
durant trois heures dans la vallée
cette randonnée pédestre de 8 km était
l'un des temps forts de cette édition
2010 8 du téléthon à magny les hameaux
ans participe depuis 11 ans au téléthon
bas pour l'esprit l'esprit du téléthon
c'est pour une bonne cause donc on est
là on est présent la ville avait retenu
comme thème cette année la chine se sont
succédé pendant 24 heures des
démonstrations de danse ou encore des
concerts tout était au profit de
l'association française contre les
myopathies
si les promesses de dons chuté cette
année au niveau national les recettes à
manille elle reste stable par rapport
aux années précédentes
dix neuf mille quatre cent cinquante
deux euros ont été récoltés pour nous
l'essentiel c'est que ce soit un moment
festif un absolument et ce moment
festival c'est faire venir les gens dans
le dans le gymnase qui prennent
confiance
ils viennent s'amuser mais pour une très
belle cause bilan positif également à
montigny le bretonneux
le complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
accueilli 1100 personnes
pour ces journées solidaires les enfants
ont pu s'initier à plusieurs ateliers
sportifs comme par exemple le handball
ça permet d'aider et puis on que ça nous
a permis une bonne image
de l'apparition de l'ensemble des
associations justement dans un événement
[Musique]
de l'argent pour tous
en tout 65 associations unies montaigne
étaient présentes pour cette édition
2010 8
ça fait partie des incontournables de
l'année ça nous fait plaisir d'être
présent et je crois que ça fait plaisir
à tous nos adhérents de se montrer et de
venir faire un petit cirque en famille
on avait beaucoup mieux nous espérons
battre à l'issue de l'année dernière
maintenant on verra après voilà les
comptes se sera pas tout de suite les
chiffres définitifs seront connus à la
fin du mois montigny l'opération
caritative
elle se poursuit sur internet